yeah yeah it's real messed up I'm just
excited about we're doing it this year
right we're do we are actually we'll
have an episode with a woo track yes I
feel like this like watching it right
here this is the best way to watch yeah
we should get together as a group and
watch everyone Chris's house yeah
Chris's house my house so I want to ask
Nicotero first you've directed a couple
season premieres now so what so this far
into the season how do I ask you this
every year but I'm always excited to see
you up your game each year so what did
you learn from previous seasons and what
are you bringing into the season
premiere well this this season was much
different because we pick up right where
we left off last year the season
premiere before we had an eight-month
gap so when Rick is in the train car at
the end of season 4 he says they don't
know who they're messing with
we get to pick up the story right away
so we didn't have to worry about telling
you guys where the characters were
because we know where they are so we're
able to pick it up so the momentum just
just blasts us off right away I got
chills I've seen it 10 times and I got
chills watching it and hearing the
anticipation in the audience it was
great I wanted should have kept going I
know well it's really because last
season last season start out pretty
sedate because the idea was that you
wanted everyone to sort of feel like
they had started to settle so that you
could then rip the earth out from
underneath them yeah but this season
like I mean you just saw just the first
couple minutes and it it just goes crazy
from there so was that did you was that
a conscious decision to say like we want
to start off season five super super
super intense yeah I think so I mean
listen Scott the writers Scott Gimple
the the show couldn't be in better hands
I love that I get to direct his scrap
because we're really good we're a great
team I feel like everyone on the show
all the actors everyone's firing on all
cylinders in this script this script was
fantastic and getting a chance to get
right into it every emotion that you
feel that you have felt in the last four
years you will feel in this one episode
you get suspense thrills emotion it all
happens in a 42 minute time period so
not a lot of comedy though there's a
little comedy there's a dance number
good don't tell them about the dance
number no okay son Scott you so last
season you started to dehl we started to
see a little bit of we saw a little bit
of Michelle's past we started delving in
a little bit are there other is that
gonna be a theme this season is starting
to unlock more about where these people
came from and who they were before
absolutely there it's gonna be more
recent past there's something about The
Walking Dead that very much exists in
the present and to that end we're gonna
have we're gonna look at the recent past
in some very very deep ways we're gonna
have some deep dives into that we're
also going to play with time a little
bit so through that we will get a really
deep look at a lot of these characters a
lot of the characters that we haven't
been able to do that just about yet with
now that was an eloquent statement not
yet with characters people yeah because
you saw it a little bit right there
between the venn and the now and you
start to see because I think it's really
important too you don't want you to
character to be black or white you know
like you want you want their kind of
alignment to be like well they're doing
what they're doing but there's probably
a reason why so is that very much so and
I mean we saw Gareth
in very different circumstances at the
beginning of this right so that's an
example of yes we're gonna try and tell
everybody's stories and get a little bit
into why they are the way they are right
Kirkman do you have you I feel like last
season you said we're gonna start to see
the show maybe begin to parallel the
comics a little bit more are you finding
more of the intertwining this season
yeah I mean there's definitely you know
what Scott's talked about this a lot in
interviews
there are a lot of big moments from the
comic book series that will be pulled
into the show this season you know we're
still going to be changing things up
quite a bit as what you can applaud
that's great you know we're still gonna
be changing things up quite a bit and
I'm very excited about these changes
they're gonna be like really cool that I
love all the twists and turns that were
taking this season but you know I think
it's safe to say that this season is
probably going to follow the comics a
little bit closer than we have in the
past you know and even and even from a
visual standpoint in in places that you
wouldn't expect to being Greg when he
directs his notebook is just full of
panels from the comic book and they
might not even be the issue that
corresponds with the story that we're at
in the moment yeah I mean when I
directed episode 9 last year which was
when they when Rick almost dies and
Karl's alone and Carl fights the walkers
that was probably the closest adaptation
that we had ever done to the graphic
novels so there were shots that there
were drawings and panels from the
graphic novel that I by the great
Charlie Adlard what's that I'll name
check that can barely out look nobody
loved Charlie I mean we but we just took
that story and added pudding that was
and now you now you can see it in the
bad lip reading yes if you have seen it
Carl I feel like we contributed to that
curse or poor Chandler because we I was
like hey let's get the word pudding
trending on talking dead yeah now last
time I saw Chandler was like people yell
pudding at me all the time now eating
eating pudding too so he did sort of
Gail if you could describe this new
season in just a handful of words how
would you pitch it to someone kick-ass
utterly relentless and totally
heartbreaking
I know hey that's good right you know
and I when I took my job it never
occurred to me that I was gonna have to
be like a therapist for people that we
would that we might lose characters that
we loved and then I'm the first stupid
face you see like
I didn't do it it is a weird thing to be
you know when we're doing the scripts
we're doing the cuts and especially at
the end of some episodes that are just
devastating which there will be a few of
those yeah
really devastating us we're not kidding
yes sorry to think I'm just I do sort of
think about what you're going to do
right afterwards you should just have
couches on talking dead everyone could
just lay on the couches and it could be
like therapy for 40 and Scott gimble can
come in is the Grim Reaper honestly
Chris I think it's our goal to get to a
point where we have at least one episode
where your little talking dead plug
afterwards is just you crying straight
to comic book men no well and that's
part of the reason why like I'll watch
it earlier in the day because if there
are emotions for me to process I feel
like I have to be strong by the time our
episode comes on so people are like
people come up to me a comic guys are
like hey man help thanks for helping me
get through that gale do you have any
anything you want to announce about
season five the second half of the
season will premiere on Sunday February
8th and you know the network right yes
come on guys
antsy and then internationally for all
of those who live outside the United
States Fox international channels and
their allied networks it will it will
launch on Monday February 9th so so you
won't have to wait too long if you don't
live here great perfect now I would now
like to bring out some people that you
probably want to see ladies and
gentlemen please welcome to the stage
Andrew Lincoln
Stephen Yin learn cohan
Michael Cudlitz
Danai gurira
Melissa McBride
Chad Coleman
Sonique will burn green
and maybe
you know Norman Reedus
come on y'all make some noise all right
nice job let's all sit down and be
patient okay okay what a reception these
can't I don't know how they just get
they get bigger every year
take it bigger every year I'm gonna
start with I want to start with an beams
like a Beatles concert selfies
I love you too hello New York what that
you're crazy put that baby face it's
amazing you guys don't even have to say
anything you could just come out and
just let them scream at you for an hour
yeah apparently so so let's start I want
to make sure we have time for Q&A
afterwards that oh that got everyone
real quiet class sit down or I will turn
this classroom around and we will go
home okay Andy let's start with you
because I think we finally at the end of
last season saw the transformative
moment where Rick came back but like
more intense it was yeah about time I
was just sick of follow me come with
those pigs so is I mean Rick had a rough
time he he lost say lost his wife he's
sensible he for all he knows has lost a
child like he doesn't know what's going
on who he is he was having this
existential crisis yeah he's now he's
Zach yeah I think I think you meet a man
very much at the peak of his powers I
think he's you know he's just bit of
guys throw it out so I mean yeah it's
it's safe to say this season I've been
listening to a lot of prodigy and death
metal you're a firestarter
I break sapphire star and smack my
up that's the song you're a parents used
to go to raves and take ecstasy that's
what they would dance to
if my mother's watching I'm so sorry so
how how this season do you do you feel
like he is grounded and intense or is he
completely spun out of control intense a
little bit of both I like I mean I think
I've loved playing him so far this
season he's just been on yeah he's been
the complete sort of package it feels is
funny because he feels a lot I kind of
regret killing Shane oh you mean the guy
who nailed your wife really no no Andy
why would you bring that up we don't we
don't regret it at all make sure you go
see fury Jon Bernthal Jon and but yeah I
think he may have been onto something
three seasons ago so I think that
there's a guy he's very uncompromising
he's incredibly driven and brutal and um
and it's been such fun I killed so
I think it's fun to see the basically
the people who the survivors start to
mimic the savagery of the walkers I mean
that moment where you rip the guy's
throat out with your teeth I mean that's
that was very much that was very much of
like hey we're all kind of we're all
kind of in the same boat yeah I mean I
think that I remember phoning Scott mr.
Kim pull up and said you know we've
always been very responsible about
violence in the show and and and I think
you know there's a line in the sand that
was drawn are we are we stepping over it
at this point and like most of the
decisions in the brilliant story telling
that my dear friend has done over the
last two three years he was absolutely
right when I did the scene you know they
were about to violate my son so you had
to it made complete sense as a you
know that was the only thing that was
available to me my teeth and I've got
particularly bad British teeth they're
not there's nothing good about my teeth
at all if you look very closely in my
mouth so they work they work
particularly well a bunch of people just
offer to look very closely at your mouth
no you really don't want to go in there
I'd like to talk to so Steven Steven
Yeun Glen - it's such an amazing arc in
the last four leading up to five seasons
and last you you almost kind of became a
hunter in a way last season trying to
find Maggie that you would stop at
nothing to find this woman that you
loved so much so how do you feel going
into season five where's where's Glenn
at now that he's found Maggie does he
still feel the same intensity or is do
you think that's gonna kind of sedate
him a little bit they get more
protective it's it's interesting to see
where every character kind of lies on
the spectrum and I think for Glenn he
still has that within him to go to those
really
I guess places where you need to go to
to survive but for him he's been
validated with hope because he woke up
in a prison with all of his loved ones
gone and he had a moment to himself and
realized if this I'm gonna go find
everybody gathers everything and in
trucks out to go and he found everybody
and so everything was yeah awesome
so everything was validated and so from
this point forward I think for him he's
like we can strive for hope we can
strive for Humanity because it worked
out for me you don't know they're in
really a really terrible situation at
the end of last season well you I mean I
think Glenn embodies that part of us
that hopes that if we were in love with
someone that we would go to those
lengths you know that we would go to
those lengths and we would even take a
swing at cutlets
yeah the smartest moves but uh you know
he let me he let me punch him that's
just because I wrote it that way look I
don't know who that was for but I guess
everyone can take it miss cohan
I love you too
what else did this what else would be
being reunited mean for Maggie with
Glenn is it do you feel is this are we
now into like now let's find Beth mode
or what what is who seems to be still
out there somewhere we're not sure we
don't know she just disappeared so where
where do you think her heads at going
into season five I think that the
amazing thing at the end of season four
was that we actually found each other
and there were points in there where it
seemed almost deluded that you'd find
your husband and then find it the rest
of your group and we saw that when
Maggie took Sasha and Bob like I'm going
it might seem crazy but I'm going anyway
and when she actually finds him I think
it gives such a sense of strength to her
that everything else is possible they
leave the prison after losing Herschel
and it's just so it's so important I
think for anyone in this group to keep
finding an actionable tasks and at that
moment it was like I'm finding my
husband and that's what I'm gonna do and
it's gonna work and it did and so now
it's moving that on to finding her
sister and she's just sort of keeping
everyone fortified you know it's we
either choose to be hopeful and to carry
on or not to so that it doesn't feel you
know I'd rather choose the former so
yeah but I even thought I even thought
the way that the show handled you guys
reuniting is the way that it would have
to be like I feel I feel like there was
a moment where it could have been super
schmaltzy and heavy-handed like and but
you barely have any time it's like oh my
god you're okay
we got to go you know it's like
there's no there's just no time to
really you just kind of have to take it
and then move on as quickly as possible
yeah I felt like he was a soldier coming
back from like I thought like I don't
even know if he's alive and oh he is oh
my god he's right there and it was
really a soldier equally you are equally
a soldier
let's not forget that she searched for
me too
but it was um thanks T but it was funny
because when we shot that scene I
remember actually running and it was
very gravely and I fell over on the way
and I thought that's real no rock will
stop Oh Maggie so I'll come to you just
stay down
mr. cutlets it's like electric shock of
hair the easiest guy to spot at
comic-con is Michael how how do you feel
since I mean we talked a little bit over
the summer you know look you're just
kind of coming into the cast coming into
the show midway through and you said you
already immediately felt like you were
just part of the group you're part of
the family how are you feeling now do
you feel like it's can you remember a
time when you weren't on the show
anymore first I want to ask who was here
last year all I gotta say is Scott
Gimple it's not a stupid he
is a smart
you know you know I really appreciate
that thank you it's the whole experience
has been fantastic I mean everybody up
here and everyone's still down in
Atlanta have been extremely welcoming I
feel I feel like at times I've been here
from the beginning I mean it really is
that warm of a creative environment in a
safe environment and and that's very
important to do the kind of work we do I
mean it's everything every single person
on this stage every character in this
world has had massive massive loss up
until this point so what we're dealing
with from day to day is loss on top of
loss and to get to those places
emotionally we you have to feel safe and
if you don't it doesn't ring true and I
was a fan of the show before I came on
the show and
I've I couldn't be more thrilled than
the reception I got and so witness the
work I work to witness the work that I
witnessed every day being done by
everybody up here how does a guy like
Abraham keep his head on like how does
he keep oh yeah of course let him have
it how does he keep his how does he keep
his head on his shoulders and focused is
it this idea of we got this guy he said
there's a mission we gotta go is he
mission driven is that what keeps him
yeah right now it's it's it literally is
saving the world yeah Eugene Eugene
holds the cure to saving the world and
we have to get him to Washington and it
you know the convoy not so sure about
that
what you know what you should just not
get in my way buddy
hey this should turn into like WWE Raw
where you guys kicked the table over and
then just chairs Smackdown Smackdown
versus Abraham yeah but is it do you
what do you think Abraham's breaking
point might be like what do you think
cuz at this point he seems pretty
level-headed like he's him one of the
more level-headed people at this point
really I think so go inside your head at
this point everybody has the hope drives
the show I think that breaking points
for any of these characters is that
point where hope seems at its smallest
yeah and the minute you lose hope that's
a very dangerous world for everybody
involved
right speaking of Hope a character that
we saw where hope started to spring
inside her was Michonne
I mean thank you girl did I remember
when you were first on the show and I
and you came on our show and I was like
yeah you know Michelle seems pretty like
pretty badass like you know pretty
focused pretend you're like you don't
even know you don't know everything
about her there's all this stuff going
on that you don't know yet and you
couldn't say because he asleep it away
but what a really like it's so wonderful
to see you know like her humanity and
really it was such a wonderful arc for
her this past season how did it feel for
you to open up that way it felt
wonderful it felt great I mean it was a
lot to be this woman that she was in the
beginning and have that type of a shield
up that type of armor on all the time
and I was it was very interesting I like
to connect with people I think of myself
as a relatively strong chick but I was
nothing like young in terms of strength
and and just her ferocity really you
know and so it was kind of like stepping
into a very daunting position and what I
loved about her though was that from the
beginning and right through what has now
happened where you know the layers have
opened up and she started to heal is
that there's always been something that
I just adore about this character and I
have to hand very directly to mr.
Kirkman and mr. Gimbel is that she's she
has a very unapologetic strength to her
and you see that in a lot of the women
characters of this show which is so
exciting to see and and it is something
where that doesn't shift like she has
evolved and opened up and and found a
way to reconnect and and found people
that she truly can love and that's
something I think she always really
wanted was to love again but she was so
scared to do it and she created such
armor around opening her heart up again
but then being around these people and
and Karl and Rick and everybody it just
she couldn't
but you know it allowed her to love
again and so I think that that was
something where her strength hasn't
shifted though that's what I found
fascinating about still playing her is
that she's still unapologetically strong
but it's a different type of strength it
hasn't it hasn't mellowed
it's just transitioned and that's really
a fascinating thing to get to play well
speaking of transitioning you know
there's this idea in a story where a
true character is revealed in a time of
crisis and watching where Carroll has
come from I mean no don't look at the
flowers you don't want to look at the
flowers well they're people shouting
look at the flowers at you all the time
even in the grocery stores don't look at
the flower but you're in the flower
section when they yell it how has this
experience been for you bringing Carol
to where she's gotten I mean she's Carol
is such an immense tower of strength and
and really a natural leader it turns out
and you have portrayed her so
beautifully what is what is who is Carol
to you and what is her journey been to
you it's been the time of my life it's
been something I'm so proud of for the
character it's been something I never
saw coming
and if I keep going out cry
because I love her yeah
hey we loved her first slow down yeah
and I think I mean this this should you
know like when these when these guys
come up here and they talk about like
what this experience is like and how its
life changing and there are family there
they're not bullshitting you I mean
they're basically in isolation out in
the middle of Georgia and they are what
keep each other going I think one of the
reasons why the show feels so authentic
and special is because your
relationships you can really feel the
you can feel the legitimacy of the of
your actual relationships bleeding
through onto the show so to see you that
passionate about Carol and being a part
of the show I just I know that it really
it makes the fans feel like that the
show is even that much more worth
watching to see that come to life that
it's amazing to work with all these
wonderful people to be so vulnerable
with each other but to be so vulnerable
with the fans because just how you
express yourself we know how much you
love and it really does feel thanks guys
so we're almost down to the end and then
we're gonna have some time for some fan
questions so if you want to in an
orderly nonviolent fashion alright Chad
Coleman Coleman how thank you
Chad how how has becoming sort of
Judith's protector like how has that
changed Tyreese how how do you think
he's feeling wow man I mean first of all
that's the most noble thing a man can do
protect a child a woman or a child
but it's it's it's an unrelenting
unforgiving world
so what we're all thinking
hey okay you're too kind but you know
like I said it's an unforgiving
unrelenting world you know it's a tough
job somebody's got to do it yeah indeed
and he has such a big heart you know he
really cares and you know community
matters to him and you know without the
children where's our future so but is it
but you know he and Carol just went
through an incredibly horrific
experience man with Lizzie and mica
so he's shaken right now man you know
it's he's uh he's hurting tremendously
and he's he has forgiven this woman and
Chad Coleman would have forgave her and
a heart because I know what kind of
woman she is it's an amazing young lady
right here an incredible actress so so
you know being able to dance with her is
you know any day anytime anywhere yeah
I'm right there but you know Tyrese is
still you forgiveness is one thing
living it out is another so he's easy
she's on shaky ground he's trying to
trying to find his footing yeah Sonique
well Martin green also so oh yes yes
huge congratulations to you
it's it's almost it's sort of almost
sort of ironic that you're coming out of
this this pretend world where there's no
hope and then you just have this like
ray of hope that's growing in you my
stomach has that affected I mean like
how is that affected the way that you
see the show or the way you've
approached the show it must have had
some kind of an effect yeah definitely I
think I think it has a subconscious
effect if not a conscious one for sure
you know you just see the value of life
you know you start to understand it on a
totally different deeper level than ever
before and it really it really makes you
tune in to the lessons and and the
prevailing messages that are being
taught on a show like this you know of
hope and survival and family and love
and making it through an adversity and
and all of that stuff you know these are
these are pillars that you want to teach
your children and you it's almost like
they enlightened they enlighten you you
know they they show themselves more
clearly when you're carrying life inside
of you oh this stupid male body we'll
never know the joys of pregnancy damn
you science now Norman Reedus
so yeah thank you
I why why now we it's it's also been fun
to kind of see the reverse happen with
Daryl of this guy who was a real
hard-ass and then every season like we
feel I feel like we peel back another
layer of him yeah and so it was nice to
see him play more emotional this last
season do you prefer that or do you like
shooting things in the face with a
crossbow a lot of times that Daryl's
killed things he's been crying he's
doing it I don't know it's you know it's
it's it goes back to what Michael said
it's you know hope drives this show and
it goes back to what these guys said and
Melissa said it's you know we really
feel connected to these characters and
we feel connected to each other and we
really care about each other so you know
teetering on that line of being
ferocious and being vulnerable is it's
it's a constant teeter totter for us you
know so everything feels really really
real you know and where is Daryl going
into season five where do you think he
is emotionally god I mean this whole
season this this well that is his new
catchphrase
all right all right around you know it's
this I mean this whole season it's kind
of like when Evel Knievel goes off that
ramp and like jumps over a bus we kind
of come out of the gate like that yeah
and probably go through a few fiery
loop-de-loops on the way through but
it's a that's kind of where all of us
are with whatever our individual
journeys are we're all just sort of like
this and I would love to tell you where
we're at right now but it it's there's a
lot of different ingredients in this
soup let's let's take some time for some
fan questions let's start with you what
is your name sir oh there you go Brad
hey Brad what's your question well Chris
thank you for coming back to moderate oh
and there was definitely something
missing last year so you are wrong would
disagree with you oh he's a bad person
so what is the way my question is for
Andrew and main even Scott I felt like
there was something missing last year in
the last episode and then when I got the
blu-ray last line from you're screwing
with the wrong people to your F in with
the wrong people
what went into that you can do what went
into that decision to uh you know change
the liner well the line the line could
have been this and and please don't
judge my acting here I'm just
interesting there's a technical thing
I'm showing it all it could have been
they're the wrong people and that what
you are looking at me like it's weird it
would have been weird they're with the
wrong people because they drop the sound
out they don't keep it they just they
drop the sound out it would have been
the last line of the season and you know
I think people would have been hitting
their sets like Homer
we did know that we were gonna be able
to do it on the blu-ray so and and you
know what Andy Lincoln can say screwing
in a way that frightens me you you know
I only did one
aye-aye-aye Oh need it I only gave one
take the actual screwing line because I
refused that is what no that's what it
says in the script yeah that that was my
own mistake because I I put in
the script oh yeah it should and you
should have I remember what you know we
get outlines and then we get the scripts
and in the outline Scott had written it
you know they're weren't the
wrong people and I said you we have to
shoot it we got to find a way so we
actually for a long time experimented
with how much can we dip the words yes
still say it yeah there were these
phrases going around the office like oh
yeah we could do a nine frame dip
oh no no we do 11 I've spent a weekend
doing that it's in the comic it's in the
comic we're cooking isn't that kind of
isn't that kind of weird though that
this is the way that television works
now and it's not their fault it's not
the network's fault it's just the way
that you can show a guy rip another
guy's throat out with his teeth you're
like all right but no swearing like
that's so weird
like if you're watching that you could
probably handle the f-bomb and kids have
the internet now anyway so it thank
you for your question what is your name
sir my name's Robert and what is your
question
I can afternoon a poem first of all I
just wanted to express that I'm looking
down the line with that exception one of
the most badass cohesive and brilliant
ensemble casts in television but I
wanted to really quickly give a shout
out to on mr. Andrew Lincoln because
from episode 1 you've given your heart
and soul to this and you're an icon yeah
I'm gonna throw this out there to you
guys and I hope that you're with me on
this one so I put this all right is
there a piece of your character's
backstory or history that is not in the
scripts but that you yourself always
keep in mind oh that's a good question
who wants to tackle that one
all right I guess Norman well there's I
mean I always imagined you know stories
with Merle that involve humiliation with
you know everything from his first kiss
- you know anything involving any sort
of accomplishment whatsoever being
squashed so I have things in my own life
that think that maybe similar to that
and so I can revert back to those things
but nothing good you know I mean I'll
never think of any good
Daryl memory but I'm making them now
with these guys yeah it took the
apocalypse to find a family what about
Steven Steven do you have any do you
have anything in your head um you know I
I imagine I know we mentioned it Glenn
mentioned his offhand to Rick that he
has couple sisters and I just imagined
him as the baby of the of the three of
them and that he was always kind of
taken care of and he was always kind of
babied in that way and you see this
post-apocalypse really just open it up
for him and he has to fend for himself
and be kind of the older brother that he
wasn't when he was younger
are you trying to sleep with you because
that's the way to do that we needs just
the baby of the group yes sir what is
your name in question - horse man oh
yeah mister horseman what does he want
he's one of the four horsemen right
there's three what is your what is your
question my original question can't be
answered because Chandler Riggs is not
here but I have a backup question Andrew
do I like Coke yeah do you want it do I
want that do you want to you know this
you want to the horse head was the weird
part but apparently
I spotted him poke up to Andrew you guys
come on
yes oh not the horse guy somebody else
give it to a security team get it crispy
you only brought one I am so thirsty now
is it warm so I think horse head guy
it's fine no he's fine
woo was an excellent pratfall I'm going
to check with am seated we get coca-cola
money for this what is your name in
question hi my name is Katherine I'm
sorry I'm shaking I've waited for years
to get to this microphone oh don't worry
you're fine you're safe you're fine
everything's good I love you guys
how does it feel because I think you
guys are the equivalent of when the
Beatles came out and they performed
twisted shout in America and people were
screaming and shaking I feel like that
is what your fan base is so how does it
feel to be like that but or that's more
of a statement that's a compliment
sorry no but I think I understand what
your questions are so epic you're so
huge like the way we feel like the way
the women would scream and shake and
piss their pants when the Beatles came
on like that's how I feel about
you guys like like hat like that's my
compliment like when John Lennon and
Paul were there like that's what you
guys are today in 2040 you my
question is because you are such amazing
actors like do you find yourself off set
off camera acting like your characters
like Norman Reedus are you like your
first drink and ain't gonna be no peach
schnapps or like you know when you're
hanging out at the bar or like andrew do
that again that was your first drink
ain't gonna be no peach schnapps
okay wait before you go here's a love
about you came up all meek like I'm
really nervous I don't know do you know
I can make women
amazing so let's let's address your
first question let's do is you're
pursuing this idea that this thing that
you guys are doing and again you are
isolated in Georgia you don't always get
to see the effect that it has on people
worldwide what how does that mess with
your head at all how does it feel or
what it like what it process that Andy
it's look it's this has been the
greatest job in my life and and we share
the same hobby you guys share the same
hobby that we do we love this show man
just as much as you love it and and we
wanna or it is or all I feel is it you
know it and I emailed Jon Bernthal a
couple of days ago and I just said every
time every time we start and launch a
new season with these amazing new actors
that join this show and I kind of think
of the original do you know the
originals you know because they built
this beautiful ensemble and taught me
I've learned so much working in this
beautiful country with these incredible
actors and I'm and it's just the most
important thing in my life this job it
just is it's just it just is and I'm and
and all of this is so I I find it quite
painful experiencing my life it's just
one of those things I kind of feel like
I have to fight all the time
you know to prove myself and and you
guys have taught me that it's alright
just showing up you know coz but but but
it's just it is an out-of-body
experience from the moment the first
comic-con I remember almost fainting
when the first trailer came out and I
was I don't watch it so but I heard you
guys next door and it made me fall to my
knees because we were getting it right
you know what I mean and that's all
we're here for to get this story right
yeah
is that does that answer that was
literally the most eloquent answer you
could have asked for I think it was a
coke I wonder if like you're out or like
you're feeling protective all of a
sudden like the cycle look comes out the
Rick Grimes you know the psycho look
thank you thank you very much thank you
cradle you alright a couple more
questions and what is your name in
question ma'am hi I'm Victoria hey
what's a question Victoria okay okay
you're gonna be like definitely times
when I've been watching The Walking Dead
before bed and found myself having
unusual nightmares at night and I was
just wondering if any of you ever have
the zombie apocalypse nightmares and if
you do what do they involve oh man I get
them just from talking about it like I
and it's gotten me you didn't ask me but
I'll tell you I I swear to God when I
know this is the honest-to-god truth
when I go to a new place I quickly scan
him like exits weapon okay like I see
what would break apart in the room and
and where the escapes are like I could
throw a chair through that window I
could probably it out that way like I
really genuinely try to process because
I have so many I'm being chased dreams
in the last four years that it's
uncomfortable I don't know does anyone
else have the same stuff I don't have
any actually it's really weird like when
I when I first I was an absolute
scaredy-cat and I didn't watch any
horror stuff whatsoever and I knew this
show was on I knew it was an amazing
show but I was like that's scary I'm
never gonna watch that and then I was
like oh now I really have to watch it
cuz after audition and then of course I
got sucked in and loved it to death but
in the beginning I really had to talk
myself through because I have trouble
falling asleep if I'm scared so I had to
talk myself through the science of a
zombie so I could sleep you know I was
like it it I'm on the second floor it
can't climb
I don't think unlock the door can't
unlock a match a window you know and I'm
really your alarm is on like I really
had to go through some stuff to figure
it out and then when I actually started
to play my character I mean I guess I
just stepped into how she thinks about
them and just but that helped actually
the science of it's like you actually
are smarter than them so you can
generally get around them generally
that's how I get through it yeah alright
good so we do the time for one more
question which I believe is you sir
Norman will we see Boondock Saints 3
anytime soon where are you by the way I
know over there um you know we're
talking about part 3 right now and it's
still it's being talked about the
storyline woods pitch to me and it's
about us and today's Sean Patrick
Flanery birthday so happy birthday John
no you don't have to do it I was just
kidding all right so is that the else no
okay I would like you to please thank
everyone who's come out here thinking
ekwa please gentlemen the cast and
producers of The Walking Dead tomorrow
night 9:00 p.m.
AMC talking dead right after at 10:00
p.m.
once again here is the exclusive
never-before-seen clip of The Walking
Dead thanks so much everyone